Stop using cold DMs to try and get your
first copywriting client because one,
you don't have any proof that you're
good at what you're doing, so they're
not going to buy. And two, if you were
good, you wouldn't be cold DMing. That's
the perception at least. So try this
instead. Start writing on a platform
like Twitter or LinkedIn in a
hyperspecific niche. Post content every
single day for 90 days. Tag the people
that you wish you could work with and
start a natural conversation with them.
Get in their DMs after you've started
talking to them and then sell them your
services or work for free until you can
build a portfolio. Organic content and
relationships is the way to grow in
2025.